[Music]
how do you tube chess lovers in my
friends this is guns in here welcome to
my thirty first episode of chest trap
series in this episode I'm going to show
you one of the high profile nasty
opening trap in the Vienna game from the
white perspective the opening arises
after the following order
efore 'if i Knight to c3 and by far the
most popular choice is Knight to f6
which has a very clear intention that
black wants to play d5 and liberate his
centre and accordingly white has tried
to popular choice Bishop to c4 leads to
the bishops opening and f4 leads to the
Vienna gambit however in my videos I
always deliver the surprise package and
this time around white come up with this
sneaky move a3 so at first sight it
looks completely ridiculous right why
why displaying this slow move in the
opening which obviously allow black to
play his thematic break defy and get a
good game well guess what this is
exactly white once now apart from defy
if you oppor and continue it either the
move Bishop to c5 or Knight to c6 then
my recommendation is you should continue
with bishops opening starting with
Bishop to c4 and a6 is always useful
because whenever this Bishop get
attacked by the knight on e5 this Bishop
can calmly retreat back to a2 anyways
let's concentrate on one of the most
obvious choice by black namely defy and
you can see the attraction of this move
not only on the 3rd move black and
challenge white Center but he can
liberate his Bishop so what can be the
more natural than this well everything
looks so good
except of one problem that just on the
third moon black has entered into the
white trappy territory the trap start
with pawn captures defy and after Knight
captures defy White has this lethal move
Queen to h5 so you can already see this
Queen is a checking on e5 and
unfortunately black cannot defend with
epics so accordingly three moves has
been tried now amongst this
I think nightcap to c3 is one of the
worst one which to my surprise played by
even a 2100 plus rated opponent but
after this move I think with accurate
play white is clearly winning yes white
has this intermediate move Queen to e5
and no matter however black blocks on
the next turn white is going to take
this Knight and emerge with an extra
pawn on the seventh move of the game so
accordingly two moose has been tried and
let's see each by turn the first woo I
want to consider is Knight to c6 which
is highest Lee played at this position
however you will be literally delighted
when you opera and play this move and as
after the move Bishop to b5 by force
white is getting very position in all
the lines if I is threatened and there
is only one way to defend this namely
Queen to d6 and after that you guessed
it yup we are going to increase the
pressure with Knight to f3
so now unfortunately for black he cannot
create another defender for the e Phi
square so accordingly there are two base
replies
the first more I want to consider is
might capture c3 which has been played
frequently in this position but after
the moody capture see three white threat
remain as it is and the only way to
defuse this threat is to play Bishop to
d7 unpinning the knight but nope that's
not going to help as after Bishop
capture c6 Bishop capture c6 and the
Moon Knight captures ePHI black doesn't
have time to capture on g2 as epsilon is
hanging and if I open plays g6 then
Queen to e2 is a very strong reply now
as per the engine the base reply
suggests is Queen to d5 which is a
multi-purpose move defending f7
attacking on g2 and most importantly
pinning down the snide but White has the
equally good reply namely Quint we do so
idea is very simple white want to
capture the bishop and then castle on
the Kings side which gives him a healthy
pawn advantage and accordingly black has
two choices the first choice is a very
bad one if black become greedy and
continue with Queen captures g2 then
after simple Moon Knight capture c6
discover check to the king and king to
d7 95 km to see it and now rook to have
fun simply gives white a healthy peace
advantage
probably the most critical response here
is castle on the queenside and after
that white responses force white has to
capture on c6 and now if black routinely
captured this night then white will
castle and remain a healthy pawn up so
the critical response goes as follows
Queen captures g2 attacking the rook no
matter what has this intermediate move
Knight captures a7 check and after King
to be it and the move rook to a fun
black has to recap to the piece with
King captures a seven here white has
tried few responses amongst them Bishop
to d2 is a most popular one however I
like this simple move FTE which confirms
a white advantage so at this point white
is a clear point up and if the Queen
will be exchanged then again the
resulting position favors the white so
obviously black is not going to
cooperate you and queen to h3 is a
logical reply keeping eye on edge to
pawn no matter what is going to play
Bishop to d2 ready to castle on the
Queen side and blacks idea is he wants
to play Bishop to d6 so not only
targeting the week s to pawn but there's
a threat in this position namely rook to
e8 and creating a problem in the e-file
well very well played by black except
what he missed out is what has this star
mu in the picture castle on the Queen
side and tactically we are saving the
pawn how
let's see it when obviously you cannot
capture with the bishop because after
rook to h1 you will lose a piece but
that's not the point
the whole point is black wants to
capture with the Queen and get his pawn
back but I think this is just an
illusion now before I go on I like
you to pause this video and find out a
continuation wear white emerge with an
extra pawn are you ready let's start the
first mode is very obvious Bishop to d6
checking the key now it doesn't matter
whether black move the king or play the
move b6
now comes Queen captures Queen Bishop
captures Queen rook captures rook rook
captures rook and the sting in the tail
looked to h1 attacking to soft spot and
black cannot defend both of them so
after Bishop to e5 and rook captures at
7 again white emerged with an extra pawn
the second move Knight to f4 is Tomas
surprised not have been played in any
games which is in fact one of the best
response by black so Black Knight is
attacking to sport so white response is
force where it has to capture on e5
and after Queen captures e5 Knight
captures defy black get his pawn back
with Knight captures g2 okay no issues
as the Queen has been exchanged of a
king is quite safe so we will continue
with King to e2 and if Knight to f4
check happened then King to f3 is a very
strong reply
do not forget why it has already a
threat namely Knight capture c6
something black has to pay attention
immediately so obvious response in this
position is Bishop to d7 saving the
threat but after Bishop captures e6 pawn
captures c6 and the move d3 yes in terms
of material it's a balanced situation
but in terms of pawn structure and
endgame scenario I think this position
is clearly better for white the simple
reason is black has some shattered pawn
on the Queen side which can be a great
target in
last but not least what happened if
black tried to defend the pond
immediately with Quinn to d6 well here
why response is very obvious we are
going to pressure on e5 with Knight to
f3 and if your opponent plays Knight to
c6 then it will transpose to the line
which we already look at it so the more
critical response here is Knight capture
c3 and after pawn capture c3 black wants
to play Knight to d7 to safeguard the e5
pawn
well we reach to another critical
position of this variation and I am very
happy to share my own novelty in this
line which has been never played in any
field games and that is Bishop to d3 two
vital point about this move first of all
it stopped any Queen exchange by black
and the second is what white wants to do
is he wants to castle and then put the
rukon even which once again pressurizing
the e5 square there are other bad
aspects in this position for the black
is this d7 Knight is blocking the Queen
side development so by force black has
to do something on the King side and
this is exactly what we hope for now it
doesn't matter whether your opponent
continued with GC or Bishop to e7 both
leads to the same crappy position which
we are about to see I like to share one
of my own game from this position
against a 2188 opponent which will give
you a clear path how good this position
is for the white my opponent here
continue with g6 attacking my queen I
responded with Queen to h4 and funny
enough Bishop to g7 is not possible as
bishop 26 is a very strong reply so in
the game
he played the value of this move Bishop
to e7 attacking the Queen well that's a
good move for white as it allowed to
speed up his development with Bishop to
g5 okay he exchanged on g5 i recapture
with queen and now black would love to
play up six but Queen two at six again
stop him to castle on the Kings side so
black decided to castle first
and after White's next good reply Queen
to h4 threatening Knight to g5 and then
looking at juicy at seven square
he stopped every single thread with f6
nobodies I keep him busy with castle on
the Queen side x-ray on the Queen
so Queen to c6 his obvious response and
now more threads with Queen 26 and I
think at this position my opponent was
tired of defending his position so he
looked for the counter play with fi his
idea is if I play Knight defy the knight
to f6 hold the ground and black is also
threatening the movie for something
which White has to keep in the mind
now why it's next reply is very obvious
h4 and there is no surprise that white
is going for the throat and if you
carefully look at this position it is
not easy to play as a black my opponent
continued with E for which turned out is
a big-time disaster as after the force
continuation night to see Phi attacking
the Queen Queen to f6 and as soon as
that Queen leaved C file there is
another check waiting Bishop to c4 King
to h8 Knight to e6 attacking the rook
and it doesn't matter wherever this rook
moves let's say in the game my opponent
continued with rook to g8 but after
Knight capture c7 it is very
clear that not only white get an
exchange but his attack on the kingside
will decide the game very quickly that's
it guys I hope with this little tricky
move a three you will provoke many of
your good opponent to continue with defy
allow him to grab the center but after
II kept his defy Knight captures defy
and the move Queen to h5 no matter
however black wriggles
he is going to struggle for the rest of
the game thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care